have you noticed that on weeks in
Westminster where it seems everything
has been set on fire you were the one
sitting in the seat on Sunday are you
number 10's human fire blanket I'm sure
it's entirely coincidental I mean I I
come on your program from time to time
because I'm very recently and I don't
recall uh anything specific but uh I'm
always pleased to come on your program I
mean I'm just thinking you know the
Dominic Cummings Story the more the week
after the local election results the
week after Boris Johnson dramatically
quitting Parliament and this is a grant
chapped week I mean things I don't think
I'm always pleased when you invite me on
I'm very happy to discuss uh the issues
of the day so it's it's good to be here
so I guess the human fire blanket today
will tell us that everything is fine in
the conservative party and what's
happening with Boris Johnson's just a
distraction well look I I think people
around the country uh you inside and
outside the party will recognize that
Boris was uh is somebody with you know
many qualities but we are now in a world
where there are different challenges um
to face and we've got new management
in number 10 getting on with the job and
getting on with the priorities of this
country like you know growing the
economy and and stopping the small boats
where we've seen some success so I think
the world has sort of moved on from what
was quite a dramatic period under brexit
and of course under the you know the the
issues related to the to covid and the
vaccine and the rest of it so do you
think it was moved on from Boris Johnson
okay I mean just factually speaking
Boris Johnson's no longer prime minister
and you know as I said I think people
appreciate I I like Boris Johnson I
worked under his administration he had
successes many successes to his name in
including breaking the brexit impasse
and including getting this country
vaccinated first but there was also
always a lot of drama that came with all
of that uh the world has moved on not
least because of whoson's invasion of
Ukraine the high
levels of inflation that created and so
things like fighting inflation and uh
growing the economy and the things that
Rishi sunac is focused on now and as you
said having some success with with
things like stop you know reducing the
number of small boats we've seen them
down 20 this year I think the world has
moved on in that regard you say that
there was always a lot of drama around
Boris Johnson which is a bit of an
understatement really
um are you hoping that now some of that
drama the soap opera if you like will
come to an end well well my my sense is
that what people want are basically the
five priorities that this prime minister
Rishi said I was wondering how tall it
would be to yeah
so someone on Twitter said please don't
let him say what the five priorities are
unless you specifically ask what are the
facts I won't give you a list but I will
say that things like stopping the small
boats as I mentioned are really
important and we're having success in
that right the numbers are down 20 yes I
mean are are we moving on has the world
moved yes yeah of course of course it's
moved on and these are things are of our
facts aren't they Boris Johnson has now
said that he is stepping down uh as an
MP so yes factually things have moved on
and now according to the newspapers this
morning this all stems partly from a
meeting nine days ago between Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson and Boris
Johnson's allies are accusing Rishi
sunak of effectively going back on his
word and not allowing through the people
that Boris Johnson or all the people
that Boris Johnson wanted to nominate
for peerages well look I don't want to
comment on individual meetings that I
wasn't
um I I can't confirm that either way
what I can say for certain is that
resisting act has not changed altered uh
the list in any way in fact there is a
House of Commons appointments uh
commission or holak as it's called which
looks at all nominations there's a very
very uh long-tested uh protocol in place
where former Prime Ministers put people
up for the house of laws I think I'm
right and saying that Gordon Brown Put
up about 50 people in his nominations
list and the Prime Minister who comes in
usually passes on in this particular
case because number 10 is actually
published the uh the the details you can
see that uh Rishi did not change that
list at all the House of Commons
commission will have made all of those
decisions and the Prime Minister has not
intervened in any way do you think Boris
Johnson didn't understand the details
then is that what you're saying
occasionally Boris wouldn't be all over
the detail I don't know whether that's
what happened in this particular case
okay
of course the real trigger was Boris
Johnson receiving the findings of the
Privileges committee report into whether
he misled Parliament over party gate he
says it's a kangaroo court he says it's
a Witch Hunt do you agree with him well
look uh Boris has seen this report I
haven't other MPS haven't seen the
report yet so I have to uh get receipts
of of that there's a formal process
that's put in place I don't want to
undermine Parliament itself which is
what coming to that conclusion uh would
do so hang on so you say come into the
conclusion that the privilege privileges
committee is a kangaroo car or a Witch
Hunt would be undermining Parliament
well Parliament itself sets up these
committees and they are uh set up in in
proportion to the current uh make up a
parliament um which is I don't know 54
conservative so there'll be
conservatives on that committee so
you're saying that Boris Johnson's
underminling I I I'm simply saying I
haven't seen that report uh only Boris
has seen it so I don't know quite what
he's getting at when he says that I
haven't seen the report I haven't seen
the evidence they presented what I do
believe is it's very important to let
committees get on with their uh work uh
you know I think the point of a member
being sent details in advance as has
happened with Boris is that it gives
somebody the opportunity to comment on
it and say no this is an accuracy here
or what have you and and challenge
elements before it's published uh as a I
haven't seen it so you're asking to
comment on something I haven't seen do I
think that the process uh is is proper
well that's the decision for Parliament
not the government but Parliament and
MPS to decide themselves and this is the
process that MPS have collectively
decided should be in place in situations
like this so Boris Johnson in his
resignation letter says there is a Witch
Hunt underway to take revenge for brexit
and ultimately to reverse the 2016
referendum result
I definitely don't feel that way I think
I'm somebody who thinks that I'm
actually having to vote for breasts as
it happens but I actually do think it's
working in favor for this country I'm
seeing how we are now able to move much
faster uh in getting on with the job in
lots of different ways uh changing rules
which enable us to bring in more
Innovative Tech and uh actually use the
advantages of being outside of the EU
but working very closely with our
neighbors and friends so I think far
from wanting to undo it I think we're in
a phase now of using the many benefits
of having that extra flexibility so no I
don't think that's the case I don't want
to get into a row about whether or not
brexit is working or not but just to say
you're not the only person uh you're not
all of your colleagues agree with you on
the treatment of Ross Johnson and the
committee report I just want to have a
look at Jake Berry MP who tweeted to say
this
you voted for brexit he's talking about
the reader if you like you voted for
brexit the establishment blocked it you
voted for Boris Johnson The
Establishment forced him out who is in
charge here the voters or the blob do
you agree with Jake Barry no
um you know actually in the end Boris
was perfectly entitled to remain as a MP
he has decided to stand down in a couple
of my uh other colleagues all the
promotions that I've worked with and uh
and and Boris in particular I I liked
working with him uh as prime minister
but as I said right at the the beginning
of this the world has moved on he is the
one who's removed himself from uh the
current sort of political um scene
standing down as a member of Parliament
and we've got excellent leadership in
place in number 10 I guess what Jake
Berry and other supporters are saying is
that they feel it's undemocratic Boris
Johnson won an election Landslide unlike
Rishi Cena by the way uh who you know
hasn't got his mandate from the
electorate in the same way that Boris
Johnson did he was elected by the voters
in his constituency of Uxbridge and
South ruislip and once again they feel
it's MPS it's his own side almost
forcing him out not the public well as I
say only only Boris Johnson himself
could make the decision as he's done to
stand down from Parliament no one well
they've said the Privileges committee is
going to give if is if we understand it
correctly is going to give him a
suspension that is so long he'd have to
face a by-election well as I say uh he's
had the benefit of seeing that committed
report it's a parliamentary committee
it's not something the government is is
doing and so these are you know these
things are Boris Johnson's decision to
do I think actually you know when you
look at I'm not going to list the five
priorities but if you look at the
priorities of this country getting on
with the the job after you know covid
and a war in Ukraine and very high
inflation those are the things that
people are really concerned about and
those are the things that this prime
minister is focused on Richard sunx well
if he's not doing a very good job is it
if you look at the polls and in the
resignation that's the one thing that
Boris Johnson does unarguably get right
is that when he left office last year
the government was a handful of points
behind on the polls that gaps widened
just a few years after winning the
biggest majority in almost half a
century that majority is now clearly at
risk you cannot argue with that that's
right and so if you basically say that
Rishi sunak is getting on with the job
because in tune with what what people
want what they're saying is we don't
really like what's what yeah I was gonna
say that's not quite the full story is
it because if you recall last summer
there were rather a lot of different
changes including a another prime
minister as well and that's when we were
a very very long way behind and polls
over 30 points behind we know from the
local elections where I think we were
nine points behind there's actually a
lot closer come on the local elections
were totally okay well even if you want
to use the same base as say the polling
was 30 points behind and it's now say 15
points behind in other words uh Rishi
tsuna focusing on people's actual
priorities stopping the small boats and
allowing the economy and and the rest of
it means that actually we are seeing
that pole got narrow but let's just be
absolutely key you know and I know you
won't want me to talk about the other
option which is a kirst armor government
but the reality is we have very low
unemployment in this country near record
levels of high employment all of that's
happened under a conservative government
and there's never been a labor
government that hasn't left unemployment
higher in history and so that's the real
challenge here is to make sure we can
preserve the things which are working
like a lot of jobs available in our
economy do you think Boris Johnson will
come back I have the one thing I know
about Boris Johnson is never predict
what Boris Johnson will will do next I
have no idea uh what will happen in
regards to that would you like to know I
I'm sure he's got many other things he
wants to get on to do it doesn't sound
like you're really gagging
he spent a huge amount he's spending a
lot of time around the world uh uh
making a lot of uh so that's what you
want to do leave the country not just
Parliament I I said hey you don't you
won't find me saying bad things about
Boris I enjoyed working with Boris I
thought he was uh I thought he was the
right man for that time particularly to
break that brexit empath which he
successfully did I thought he was very
good leading in leadership of the world
in Ukraine after the invasion and other
things but a lot of drama came with it
we've got a series of very important
things that we're focused on now like
reducing inflation and growing the
economy and those things are starting to
work we see Germany in recession the
Eurozone in recession this country
actually escaping recession uh because
we've got the right measures in place
under Rishi well and I think lots of
people would say that if you look at the
economic situation if you really want to
go down the argument about what economic
situation we're in with a you know
mortgage sort of Time Bomb inflation
much stickier than expected I'm not sure
that that's really the strong point that
you'd be fighting zero growth well I
just say first of all it's not zero
growth we just had the biggest upgrade
uh of any uh country uh in I think the
iron flatlining Grace within the UK and
no uh they're actually predicting growth
this year and what uh I think 0.5 uh
percent point seven percent uh is is
possible depending on which uh uh
economists uh you follow uh remember
that six months ago they said that we
would be in recession remember that
Germany is in recession that the
Eurozone is in recession and I know
there's a kind of desire to sort of
constantly say somehow that we're doing
worse than everyone else our economy
grew faster
than the year before I'm just I'm gonna
be right up there this year I'm not I'm
not saying that what I'm saying is we
have 0.5 predicted inflation running at
around ten percent
this is a fall in real incomes and it's
really really really difficult for
people right now and I don't think we
should necessarily be you know rubbing
our hands look I'm not in any way shape
or form saying that I am saying that
things like unemployment are great
achievements but that's why the first on
the list of five that you won't allow me
to mention is to get to halve inflation
and it is why uh you know inflation's
like attacks on people it is why we're
working so hard on that uh it's why
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor and Rishi are
so focused on that as their first
priority it costs everybody when
inflation's high and that's why we're
we're pressing down on it uh you've got
a couple of by-elections coming up now
because not only is Boris Johnson
standing down but two of his key allies
are as well could be pretty tricky
particularly in Uxbridge when you're a
performer party chair how confident are
you feeling about that yeah I look at it
we will fight for every vote as a every
former and current party chair will tell
you
um and we'll be presenting our our
message and what we'll be saying to
people in Oxford or elsewhere is look
since the only other viable option to
run the country is is kirst armor or a
combination of him and the lib Dems and
the s p goodness knows what else know
what you're voting for which in you know
just in the last week we've seen labor
either pledging or not pledging 28
billion pounds of tax and spend uh on a
program which is in a in a mess uh and
uh and and doing whatever just stop oil
tell them should be their policy on
energy my area which would cost families
a fortune that 28 billion uh pledge is
about a thousand pounds per family they
want to put our energy policy in the
hands of people they would argue I mean
look I'm going to talk about the 28
billion policy with labor as you'd
expect but they would argue that this is
actually about energy security something
that people really really care about and
it's also about creating Half Men and
it's extraordinary that their actual
policy would create energy insecurity
make us reliant on tyrants like Putin by
importing gas and oil uh that we need
still as we make that transition to
netzera we end up importing it from
abroad and we're still we're double the
carbon it's a completely illiterate
policy that they've got from their their
from their just stop oil friends well
let's let's talk we'll talk about that
policy with labor
um I just want to talk to you about one
of your uh policies as well if I may
because you know there has been some
criticism by Boris Johnson for vicious
you know not following through with some
of his plans it feels like one of them
could be the plan for Great British
Railways when that's your baby you're
trying to fix the way that Railways are
fragmented if you like and the times
have reported that it won't be in The
King's Speech it's being watered down no
legislative powers to sign off contract
to set fares are you a bit worried so
just be absolutely clear Great British
Railways is happening as I understand
I'm no longer transport secretary you
have the transport secretary talk about
it but uh it is happening it is a
different way to arrange the the
railways an awful lot of what's required
doesn't require a major Act of
parliament immediately to get that going
so the body itself is being established
I think it's going to be based in Derby
the competition uh was was announced for
the headquarters a lot of what's
required can be done by repurposing the
kind of vehicles that are already there
so I think the question of at what point
do you have to pass the so-called
primary legislation through Parliament
is separate to getting on with the job
of reorganizing the way the railways run
and that's continuing okay and the thing
that you want to talk to about today is
more funding to support people with
health issues to stay at work what can I
do look we we have uh as I say a great
track record on employment but we're
also aware and particularly post covered
are people who've found it difficult to
stay in the workplace or are dropping
out of the workplace the funding that
we're making available to ensure that
people can stay and work and are
supported to do so we think where people
can be economically active it's better
for them it's better for their health is
better for the economy as well okay and
just finally uh we're going to be
talking to the BMA later on the program
because of course Junior doctors are
striking next week part of a
long-running uh dispute we'll get their
View later but what's your message to
them simply this you know first of all
to the whole of the Health Service and
the NHS uh you know we really want to
see the service working for people is
why one of the pledges that I won't
mention is to cut the waiting lists
which I won't list in detail which is
cut the waiting list
um and one of the things we need to do
as a responsible government is press
down on inflation as well we can't be in
a situation where we end up in the
spiral of pay claims which bust
inflation and end up in a position where
we never get inflation out the system so
it's about coming to a fair settlement
both for the junior doctors and for the
rest of the public service and frankly
people who don't work in the public
service to make sure that we are uh
getting that balance right and that's
what we're trying to do I really hope
that these uh industrial disputes can be
brought to a close so we can all get on
with the things we're we're trying to do
for example we've got rid of the
two-year weights we've got rid of 90
percent of the 18-month weights we're
making progress with the NHS recovery
replan post covert